- [Instructor] A quality control expert
at a drink bottling factory
took a random sample
of bottles from a batch and
measured the amount of liquid
in each bottle in the sample.
The amounts in the sample
had a mean of 503 milliliters
and a standard deviation
of five milliliters.
They want to test if this
is convincing evidence
that the mean amount for
bottles in this batch
is different than the target
value of 500 milliliters.
Let mu be the mean amount of liquid
in each bottle in the batch.
Write an appropriate set of hypotheses
for their significance test,
for the significance test that the quality
control expert is running.
So pause this video and
see if you can do that.
Now, let's do this together.
So first, you're going
to have two hypotheses.
You're gonna have your null hypothesis
and your alternative hypothesis.
Your null hypothesis is
going to be a hypothesis
about the population
parameter that you care about
and it's going to assume
kind of the status quo.
No news here.
And so the parameter that we care about
is the mean amount of liquid
in the bottles in the batch.
So that's mu right over there.
And what would be the
assumption that that would be,
the no news here?
Well, it would be 500 milliliters.
That's the target value.
So, it's reasonable to say,
well, the null is doing
what it's supposed to,
that where the actual mean for the batch
is actually what the target needs to be,
it's actually 500 milliliters.
Some of you might have said,
hey wait, didn't they say the amounts
in the sample had a
mean of 503 milliliters?
Why isn't this 503?
Remember, your hypothesis is going to be
about the population parameter.
Your assumption about
the population parameter.
This 503 milliliters right over here,
this is a sample statistic.
This is a sample mean
that's trying to estimate
this thing right over here.
When we do our significance test,
we're going to incorporate
this 503 milliliters.
We're going to think about,
well, what's the probability
of getting a sample statistic,
a sample mean this far or further away
from the assumed mean if we assume
that the null hypothesis is true,
and if that probability
is below a threshold,
our significance level, then
we reject the null hypothesis
and it would suggest the alternative.
But if we're just trying to generate
or write a set of
hypotheses, this would be
our null hypothesis, and then
our alternative hypothesis
is that the true mean for the batch
is something different
than 500 milliliters.